so what else is in the box that
Activision bungee and redbull partner to
give us well comes with a free destiny
digital download that's it but let's go
back to the camp there's something else
in here isn't that right Andy I hope so
oh look at that so you flip the top here
and the code is underneath the opening
here let me put the code in well L 77 3
3 4 4 p-8 77 k 4 for it that's it it's a
countdown clock look at that 80 days
congratulations hey hold on John shaggy
oh look at this triage follow the link
below to claim my Lou Joshi getting this
they're getting this right here so I
want to claim this loop at bungie.net
right I'm already signed in on there you
go playing it's another claim so give me
the cam here that's the can that I Chris
checks out all right let's check south
in the heat of the moment and focused
light whoo item of lville pick up all it
comes to the postmaster on july first so
early there you have it we're a little
too early but you get the Red Bull so
you could sip that until that day july
first for all of your unboxing videos
you get a gamespot com take care now
become legends of bling quartet I'm not
trying to turn a meeting that he needed